I'm Dan richer Chef Restaurant owner and
author today I'm here to answer your
questions from Twitter this is pizza
support
[Music]
first up Melissa Dorman says the real
question that makes up life why does
pepperoni curl Pizza bakes from the top
down but also from the bottom up and
there's a differential between the
pepperoni that's cooking from the top
and the pepperoni on the bottom touching
cold cheese and sauce so as the heat
from top down bakes it the casing kind
of shrinks it a little bit and the edges
start to pop up next up Nifty normo asks
people making a big deal out of eating
pineapple on pizza but what about the
folks eating anchovies ham and pineapple
pizza originated in Canada of all places
not in Hawaii if you grew up eating
pineapple on a pizza you just go right
ahead don't listen to them anchovies are
great on a pizza filled with salty
savoriness it's Umami I personally don't
like a mouthful of anchovies so what I
do is I take my anchovies with some
olive oil on the stove and just let it
cook for about 45 minutes until they're
completely melted into the oil and then
I drizzle that on top of the pizza
that's like the Gateway for people to
like anchovies next up Nom Nom MTL asks
any good Cooks out there know what the
best cheese is for making pizza are
Google's no help if we want to bake the
pizza with the cheese on it I always
recommend good melters young cheeses
like fresh mozzarella or gray Swiss
cheeses Raclette Fontina phenomenal for
pizza other cheeses like goat cheese
that don't melt Parmigiano-Reggiano it's
great cheese for pizza put them on after
you bake the pizza cheese is a
combination of fat water and it's all
held together with protein we need that
fat and moisture to be in balance and
held together by those proteins so when
it hits the oven it melts and flows onto
the pizza so we have two Margarita
pizzas here same cheese but this cheese
was made yesterday and this cheese was
made about 10 minutes ago this one flows
more we're gonna have nice long cheese
poles the cheese is going to be tender
and creamy whereas this one even though
it was made 24 hours ago the cheese kind
of stayed put clear lines where it
stopped flowing and melting for
mozzarella cheese you want to use the
freshest cheese that you can possibly
find next up important question for
pizza Twitter mushrooms on pizza cooked
or raw always cooked it's super
important mushrooms have a ton of liquid
in them so as they bake they release a
lot of liquid we want that liquid to
release before we put them on a pizza
next question Eric V Bailey asks what
makes a pizza sauce a great pizza sauce
great tomatoes make a great pizza sauce
we want to use whole peeled tomatoes
that taste delicious once you have those
Tomatoes treat them as simply as
possible pizza sauce is pretty much
never cooked in advance we take the
tomatoes maybe a pinch of salt we adjust
their viscosity by either straining them
a little bit if they're too loose we're
adding just a touch of water to loosen
them up this is called a boxwick
consistometer this is what tomato
canneries use to control their viscosity
and keep their product very consistent
and reliable from canned again and from
year to year they put a sample of their
sauce on here specific amount at a
specific temperature
and then they time it to see how far and
how fast it flows we want to use whole
peeled tomatoes because that's typically
the best in show for each tomato
manufacturer next question Evan semila
asks what's the most important part of a
pizza is it the cheese sauce or dough
there's no one right answer here what
are you trying to achieve in your pizza
I actually came up with a list of 60
different characteristics about pizza
that I loved and that I wanted to create
and those are my product specs it's also
my training manual for our kitchen team
here at the restaurant this pizza
evaluation rubric everything from the
build of the pizza the bake the
structural Integrity of it how
caramelized the rim is we're looking for
big open holes in the crust separated by
Thin pearlescent cell walls flavors of
fermented wheat the cheese has 10
characteristics tomatoes have eight
characteristics when you make pizza you
want to have your end product in mind
there's no way you can build a house
without a set of blueprints next up
Allen
4023 asks what is the best type of oven
for cooking a pizza the best type of
oven for cooking pizza is the oven that
you have access to I have access to this
beautiful Wood-Fired oven this is my
preferred method for baking a pizza and
it's not because of how hot it is
everyone thinks it has to be 900 Degrees
for it to make great pizza that's not
the reason why we love wood-fired pizza
the reason we love it is because it's
huge since it's such a large oven we
have so many areas to move the pizza as
it bakes we can actually put the pizza
in a spot of the oven where that pizza
just wants to be as long as your oven
reaches a minimum of 475 degrees you can
make great pizza cooking a pizza below
475 degrees you're not going to get that
oven spring which is that rapid rise of
the pizza dough as it bakes you're also
not going to get great caramelization
and I like crispy pizza next up oh wild
UK says people who make pizzas at home
how necessary are pizza stones pizza
stones are vital to making great pizza
in your home oven you can use a pizza
stone a pizza steel or just some fire
bricks that you can get for two dollars
each at any big box hardware store I buy
pizza steals which is just a thick
quarter inch half inch plate of Steel I
don't ever take it in or out of the oven
it just stays in the oven making my oven
more efficient so when I launch a pizza
into the oven the pizza has direct
contact with this very hot surface and
that's what's going to cause the pizza
to rise that oven spring the thermal
mass is crucial to getting your pizza
dough crispy and fully baked from the
bottom up next up Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles most underrated pizza topping
I'd say corn I was traveling in Japan
about 15 18 years ago and I saw a
pepperoni and corn pizza and a few years
later when New Jersey was having a great
corn season I remembered it and now it's
our biggest selling seasonal Pizza all
year next up homo Wendy asks anyone have
any ideas on coolish dough this is our
pizza dough pizza dough is made up of
flour water salt and yeast of some sort
a poolish is what we call a pre-ferment
that means before we mix our final pizza
dough we actually take some of the flour
water and yeast and we mix it together
the night before and we let it sit at
room temperature fermenting and getting
gassy and bubbly and filling with
flavors so polish is one type of
pre-ferment there's also Biga and
there's also sourdough I wish you guys
can smell this it is so flavorful look
at that gas oh my God the flavor that
this is going to introduce into my pizza
dough today is the essence of pizza next
up chatty Campbell says do pizza makers
have to toss the pizza up in the air or
is that just a fun little thing they
like to do you certainly don't have to
toss your pizza dough up in the air I
certainly don't if you're too aggressive
with it you tend to knock out all the
gases that were built up through
fermentation you need the gas to create
a lightness and a crispiness and an
areas next up ham salad ass I'm getting
better at making pizza dough but how do
you make it less bready does it need to
proof longer more kneading you know it
doesn't look bad but actually cheese
needs a little bit of help we have a
little bit too much Browning and it's
not flowing and melting very well so I
would turn the oven temperature up I
would also increase the hydration of the
dough to help the heat transfer more
efficiently and you definitely have to
use a pizza stone next question sodas at
sundown asks just a random question but
do you know how to cook pizza I do let
me show you first we need our pizza
dough we're gonna dust a little bit of
flour on top flatten it out and then
we're going to start to extend it you
could just pick it up in the air and let
it hang and let gravity do the work or
you can pick it up on the back of your
hands and use your knuckles keep
stretching it until it's about 10 inches
I'm gonna have a little bit more flour
over here the main thing is to keep the
dough nice and dry one drop of water
underneath this pizza crust it's gonna
make it all stick then we're going to
add our sauce less sauce is always
better so we have fresh mozzarella here
extra virgin olive oil tiny bit I like a
little bit of coarse sea salt so now I
have my pickup peel and then we're going
to launch it in
so once I see the first signs of
caramelization then I'm going to start
to rotate the pizza and see a little bit
of caramelization starting to occur on
the bottom and that is a fully baked
pizza
next up Simon McKellar asks does a
calzone count as a pizza a calzone is
basically a pizza folded in half and
then baked in the oven so it's kind of
like a pizza pocket no it does not count
as pizza but it's pizza's cousin next up
luciletics says how can you ever have
too much cheese on a pizza it's very
possible Pizza is a flat bread with
condiments baked onto it now if you
overload your pizza with condiments
there's not going to be enough strength
in the dough to keep it supported we
need structural Integrity in our pizza
if we're gonna pick it up with our hands
Tim Meisler asks should I order two
medium pizzas or one large here's the
math
extensive algebra yes you're right there
is more surface area on one 18-inch
pizza versus two smaller pies good work
next up tersha can I put a pizza box in
the oven will it burn do not put a pizza
box in the oven please fire hazard from
stinky Think Tank best way to reheat
cold pizza I like the toaster oven you
can also use a cast iron skillet on a
medium high flame on your stovetop just
please whatever you do don't use the
microwave the way that the heat waves
are transferred to the pizza is just not
good for any bread products next up
ultimate says what's the best style of
Pizza Detroit New York California
Chicago I don't know what the best style
of pizza is I like them all and you
should try them all but let's say
Detroit style it's a rectangular Pizza
baked in a pan cheese goes all the way
to the edges tends to get a little
crispy New York style pizzas are big
pick them up with your hands cut in a
triangle fold it they're a little bit
pliable a little bit crispy I love when
they're super hot and they burn the roof
of your mouth California Pizza local
produce they're surrounded by farmland
and they kind of just run with that plus
they're also not bound by authenticity
tradition Chicago deep dish pizza is
baked in a pan there tends to be a lot
of fat it's really heavy it's very rich
kind of a fork and knife thing it's
called pizza but it's its own unique
individual thing unwinder H asks it's
always driven me crazy that people say
the pizza in New York is so much better
than the pizza anywhere else why can't
it be replicated is there something in
the New York City Municipal Water Supply
that's one of the most frequently asked
questions that I get it is not about the
water there's always little Corrections
that we can make for the minute
differences in the mineral content in
the water if you understand the
ingredients and the techniques behind
New York style pizza you can make it
anywhere in the world the water has very
little to do
with the quality of your pizza next up
Cory blog says I don't get oil on pizza
does it like add flavor but oil doesn't
taste good if you use the right oil it
absolutely tastes good some flavors are
fat soluble so you need fat for your
brain to be able to really pick up those
flavors we would never use a neutral oil
like vegetable oil canola oil grapeseed
oil those are meant for high temperature
cooking for pizza and salads we like
high quality extra virgin olive oil
stuff is liquid gold Phil Willis says or
San Marzano Tomatoes really that great
or is it just a way of flexing your
knowledge of cooking trivia you do not
need San Marzano Tomatoes San Marzano is
a small small region in Italy just
outside of Naples they're known to have
amazing volcanic soil and really
delicious Tomatoes but they can't
possibly produce enough tomatoes in this
very small region of Italy to meet
worldwide demand line up five different
tomatoes that are in your Supermarket
taste it and find what you like and use
that tomato next up Shy socks history
how much would it cost to open a
pizzeria well that depends on how much
money you got to spend I've seen people
do a food truck for thirty forty
thousand dollars you can open a pizzeria
for a hundred and fifty thousand dollars
if it has pre-existing restaurant
infrastructure like the proper Plumbing
the proper permits the proper
electricity or you can spend 10 million
dollars to open Pizzeria there's no
right or wrong here next up Gene marigag
asks best pizza dough recipe please
share right now because I needed to rise
before dinner time there's no best
recipe for pizza but here's a very
simple one a thousand grams of flour 750
grams of water 20 grams of salt and 2
grams of yeast and I can show you how to
make pizza dough right now before we
start mixing the flour and water one of
the most crucial parts of of the process
is to control our temperatures
fermentation and the activity of the
yeast is determined by the temperature
we want our dough to start fermentation
at 75 degrees today so we do 75 times 3
which is 225 and then we're going to
subtract out the room temperature which
is 82. we're going to subtract out the
temperature of our flour which right now
is 75 degrees and we're going to
subtract out the amount of heat
generated by actually sticking my warm
hand in here and mixing it that's called
the friction Factor now for hand mixing
maybe one or two degrees of heat is
generated by friction if you use a dough
mixer it could be 40 50 degrees of heat
generated so I'm going to build in one
degree that spits out my water
temperature to use if I use that water
temperature for this dough I know my
dough is going to start fermentation at
75 degrees this part of the process is
so crucial don't even mix flour together
unless you know your temperature of
water we're going to add the yeast to
the flour and give it a little stir and
then we're going to start adding our 67
degree water then we're going to wait 20
minutes and this part is called the auto
lease there's an enzymatic reaction that
starts occurring where amylase naturally
present in flour starts to convert
starch into simple sugars that the yeast
can then consume we're also allowing the
flour to fully hydrate gluten
development begins all right so we just
let our pizza dough rest for 20 minutes
and we're going to mix in the salt and
we're going to begin kneading and I'm
just doing this scooping and digging
motion it's strengthening the gluten and
it's also incorporating a little bit of
air into the dough which is a good thing
it's creating these little micro bubbles
called nucleation sites those little
tiny bubbles are going to fill with gas
that the yeast produce we're going to do
this for five minutes okay then we're
gonna let it it next up Kira please asks
what should never go on a pizza if you
can dream it it should go on a pizza is
Alyssa okay asks does Pizza in Italy hit
different yes it does Italy is a
different place with a different history
of pizza different local ingredients
different local traditions and different
styles there's Neapolitan style pizza
which is 12 inch pie baked in a very hot
oven there's Roman Pizza Tonda which is
a round thin crispy pizza baked in a
lower temperature Wood-Fired oven
there's pizza allapala and bakeries
there's Pizza italio there's so many
different styles of Pizza in Italy it's
such a special thing Blue Dog Pizza asks
eating pizza with a fork and knife is it
A-Okay or a pizza faux pas I think it's
perfectly okay to eat pizza any way you
choose alright that's it that's all the
questions hope you learned something and
until next time
[Music]